tout le 25 février dernier
j'ai produit un spectacle devant 300
personnes le d'accord chaud pourtant je
suis ni comédiens ni producteur ni
artistes je suis juste président d'une
association d'accord qui oeuvre à
améliorer les conditions de vie des
personnes en situation de handicap
nos objectifs 3 premièrement créer des
lieux de rencontres en dehors des
établissements spécialisés
deuxièmement créé ailier des moments
festifs des moments de loisirs dans des
lieux ordinaires
troisièmement les troisièmement
rencontrer des personnes avoir des
échanges avoir une ambiance et ces
échanges permettent entre parents entre
jeunes entre éducateurs quelque part de
participer à une autre insertion sociale
je suis moi même papa du jeune fille de
27 ans giovanna grande prématurée
atteintes de déficience visuelle est
atteint de déficience intellectuelle
j'ai rencontré cette jeune fille à l'âge
de six ans en même temps que je
rencontre et sa maman ce fut le
changement radical de ma vie non
seulement je rencontrais la femme de ma
vie mais j'avais le cadeau
extraordinaire de pouvoir partager une
complicité et un amour sans filtre je
décide a donc le jour de mon mariage
d'adopter la petite fille de mon épouse
je veux non que son papa
au début de cette rencontre l on se pose
des questions on se dit comment agir
comment se conduire
il semble que c'est compliqué mais en
fait non ces enfants sont sans filtre
ils sont purs c'est vrai ou faux même si
quelquefois leur faciès ne peut nous
faire peur ou leur façon de s'exprimer
nous choque l'hypocrisie la manipulation
ils ne connaissent pas c'est blanc ou
noir
il dégage une émotion extraordinaire
dans leur sincérité
mais il ya un mais mesdames messieurs on
ne les connaît pas parce qu'on les fait
vivre dans un monde en vase clos
ce monde en vase clos m'a permis de dire
je vais produire ce spectacle et l'idée
m'est venue de ma fille giovanna elle
adore la musique elle est passionnée par
le chant depuis son plus jeune âge et
nous avons vu la métamorphose que
pouvait apporter cette passion à
giovanna l'idée de partager cette
expérience avec d'autres handicapés
mentaux va créer un autre chemin dans
notre association lors d'un après midi
festif
nous adhérons se met à chanter se met à
danser et nous avons l'idée et j'ai
l'idée d'inviter des artistes des
chanteurs des humoristes des profs de
danse des danseurs ils découvrent avec
nous ce nouveau monde
mais en même temps il découvre quelques
talents en les écoutant chanter qu'en le
regardant danser alors avec eux et leur
engagement
mais il nous prend une idée complètement
folle si on monte un très grand
spectacle où artistes et jeunes
handicapés seraient sur scène mais aussi
en coulisses
ce projet nous donne quelques objectifs
en fait la découverte de nouveaux
métiers artistiques et technologiques à
nos jeunes handicapés deuxièmement sur
une scène un peu de paillettes un peu
d'éclairage et un bon sens et artistes
et jeunes handicapés ont fait gommer les
différences on oublie la différence on
voit pas qui est qui le troisième
objectif c'est que la rencontre que nous
permet d'une telle organisation
d'entreprise de structures privées
publiques nous amène à que ces gens
aussi découvre ce nouveau monde et on
peut être un peu l'idée de dire me tiens
il ya des nouvelles voix peut-être une
nouvelle possibilité d'insertion sociale
car je vous pose la question quel avenir
propose tôt à nos jeunes handicapés
mentaux
quelle que soit la cause ou les
complications de l'handicap mental ils
sont accueillis dans interdite dans un
établissement spécialisé en dehors de la
vie ordinaire
maintenant giovanna à 20 en 20 ans c'est
l'heure des choix
c'est leur aussi de la légalité faut
savoir ces jeunes handicapés leur âge
légal et vingt ans ils n'ont pas 18 ans
lors des choix pourquoi parce que les
tutelles décide moment donné calais va
être leur orientation je dis bien des
tutelles les alternatives sont réduites
de choix le premier il décide qu'en
fonction de l'heure de leur comportement
ils sont capables d'accomplir certaines
tâches et en ce cas dans ce cas là ils
seront accueillis dans un établissement
spécialisé de travail protégé qu'on
appelle des esat
s'il décide que la personne n'est pas
capable de pouvoir accomplir certaines
tâches musée il rentre dans un
établissement spécialisé où ils vont
avoir diverses activités dans la journée
ils vont se retrouver ensemble on leur
on les aide un petit peu à voir leur
autonomie mais toujours en dehors de la
vie ordinaire
pourtant pourtant si on regarde un peu
en europe et dans des pays près de nous
en espagne en suède par exemple handicap
ou pas le seul critère d'embûches
c'est la compétence les établissements
spécialisés ont su se transformer leurs
missions évoluer mais plutôt vers une
mission plus sociale yz toutes les
personnes en pro en propre avec des
problèmes médicaux il c'est de
l'accompagnement médical
il aide aux logements mais ils sont
surtout formateur formateurs
professionnels
ils sont même le tremplin al embauche
en fait ils ont réussi leur insertion
sociale et que se passe-t-il
mais messieurs mesdames quand ces gens
souffrent ou sont dans la rue et qu'il
rencontre maintenant des personnes en
situation d'handicap mental
il détourne plus leur visage pourquoi
parce qu'ils ont inventé le vivre
ensemble ils ont inventé un mode
d'inclusion en france revenons à nos
établissements spécialisés en travail
protégé en fait si je vous résume ce
sont des établissements ou dans un même
atelier vous retrouver des gens de
pathologies différentes de tout âge
accomplir un peu de ménage un peu
d'euros passage un peu de l'emballage un
peu de façonnage et celle entre 20 ans
et 60 ans donc c'est ce travail en plus
et fournis par des entreprises c'est
très bien qu'ils soient fournis par des
entreprises
les entreprises bénéficient à ce moment
là de bien évidemment qu'ils ont
accompli leurs obligations légales dans
bosch d'handicapés mail handicap ne
rentre pas dans l'entreprise
je suis là pour dénoncer ce modèle
puisque pour moi ce modèle est dépassé
en france
le modèle est basé sur une protection
sociale mais je m'interroge
mais qui veut ton protéger contre qui
contre quoi ces établissements
spécialisés de jeunes handicapés ont un
taux d'absentéisme qui est inférieur au
taux d'absentéisme des entreprises on
voit que le travail qui est accompli
il est accomplie de manière avec de la
qualité et dans les délais mais alors
pourquoi les entreprises on n'embauche
pas il embauche pas ils en mangent pas
aujourd'hui parce qu'ils ont peur ils
ont peur pourquoi parce que on ne les
connais pas on ne connaît pas nos jeunes
handicapés on a peur de leur
comportement parce qu'on ne les voit pas
dans la vie ordinaire
je serais même à me demander si ça te
lois de protection sociale n'est pas
pour protéger
les personnes dites normales contre
l'exposition des personnes handicapées
alors là je risque dire un gros mot ce
serait de la discrimination c'est un mot
qui est à la mode aujourd'hui d'ailleurs
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on change la
proche cette approche ce modèle est
complètement dépassé
ce qu'on peut retrouver aujourd'hui qui
peut nous donner espoir c'est que la
jeune génération d'handicapés a
aujourd'hui découvre à travers les
technologies à travers la communication
ils ont tous leur iphone leur pc leur
réseaux sociaux y voi x qui peuvent se
créer de nouvelles alternatives pour eux
et pour nous car aujourd'hui on n'est
pas étonné que des choses secret on a vu
des défilés de mode s'appelle modèle
handicap on a vu des personnes
handicapées créer de l'entreprise être
dans l' embauche dans l'hôtellerie dans
les salons de coiffure on a même des
exemples très fort une jeune handicapée
mentale qui par la volonté et l'aide de
tout le monde est devenue institutrice
rendez compte
et puis et puis il ya quelque temps on
l'est peut-être tous vu à la télé une
personne handicapée mentale ou
trisomiques qui a passé qui a réussi son
rêve de passer à la télé faire faire une
minute et demie de météo
on est tous très heureux qu'elle ait pu
réaliser son rêve
mais quelques avons nous constaté que
tout le monde a trouvé ça très émouvant
oui c'est émouvant
mais pourquoi c'est émouvant parce qu'on
n'a pas l'habitude de la voir dans la
vie entière et je souhaite de tout mon
coeur que cette petite expérience ce
petit rêve il puisse se transformer en
quelque chose qu'elle puisse continuer
dans la voie qu'elle a envie de faire
qu'on lui en donne les possibilités oui
car pour moi la france c'est un handicap
à traiter le handicap
je reviens sur notre spectacle quand
nous l'avons réalisé effectivement il y
a eu une grande joie auprès de ces
jeunes se sont sentis moins différent on
a vu leur sourire mais on a vu aussi
quelque chose qui s'est réalisé pour eux
lors d'une répétition qui ont duré six
mois
il a fallu trouver des endroits on
appris des lieux ordinaires mais on n'a
pas eu le choix parce que ça a pété que
des endroits privés qui nous ont ouvert
les portes
ces lieux ordinaires avec des personnes
des bénévoles des artistes qui qui n'ont
pas l'habitude d'accompagner des jeunes
handicapés qui sont comme vous et moi
mais simplement il avait une âme ur de
métier il avait l'amour de faire passer
leur leur passion et le résultat ces
jeunes et bien vous a vu à l'ecoute
discipline et apprendre leur texte et
surtout messieurs mesdames
ils ont réalisé quelque chose
d'extraordinaire qui est difficile de
réaliser
j'en suis la preuve aujourd'hui donc je
pense vraiment qu'il faut qu'on change
de modèle de cette expérience qu'est ce
que nous avons pu rencontrer aussi que
les entreprises qui nous ont suivi nos
partenaires qui nous ont suivis dans
notre projet envie de continuer
l'expérience ils se disent peut-être
qu'il y a avec ce nouveau monde avec ces
nouveaux gènes des possibilités de
nouveaux business de nouveaux marchés
peut-être même de bénéfices
donc je pense vraiment qu'il est temps
qu'on change notre regard il est temps
de transformer les institutions vers un
modèle d'inclusion pourquoi pas rêver
que institutions entreprises
associations tous main dans la main joue
ce rôle
vers un modèle d'inclusion et je rêve
aussi que mon association puisse créer
un établissement on l'appellerait eesad
non pas exact établissements du sourire
pour artistes différents
car l'art est source d'emplois mais
aussi d'amour et de passion
on pourrait peut-être donner une autre
expérience une autre vision assez jeunes
handicapés
et surtout messieurs mesdames une autre
voie dans un monde sans différence mais
surtout sans indifférence
merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]